Hi everyone.
My name is Elise spark Hoffer and I'm
one of the global program managers for
women at Google. We were very excited
today for a special talks at Google,
hosted by Eileen Naughton,
VP of people operations at Google and
Marine Schuchat Marine Schuchat began her
career in marketing at L'oreal Paris
in 1985 she has worked at the gap help
launch old navy and was president of
Banana Republic before becoming COO and
president of US operations of Chanel
in 2003 in 2007 she became it's first
global CEO where she oversaw the
business and brands worldwide expansion.
She left Chanel in 2016
to focus on writing,
speaking and developing
new leadership initiatives.
There is a dory for questions.
I'm go slash Maureen Hyphen Dori.
If anyone who's over live stream wants
to add a question remotely when we open
it up.
Thanks.
Thank you Lisa,
and good morning,
everyone know the afternoon if you're
watching from other parts of Google,
we have I think,
well over 200 people signed up,
so good morning everyone on the GBC
and welcome back to Google Morgan.
Thank you.
Maureen and I ran into each other in
the hallway this morning and one of the
reasons I was so intrigued come in and
speak with you was I met Maureen in the
past. She was, um, at
the time, CEO of Chanel,
one of the most coveted
accounts in the New York office.
I might add on all of our sales
executives from transcend very,
very specially when the
Chanel team came in. Uh,
and they got a lot of
love from us and Maureen,
you were really pushing your team to,
uh,
drive more value through
digital marketing.
And so clearly a lot of
leadership insight there.
But I read the book review, uh, uh,
beyond the label Marines first book.
Um,
and I was intrigued and I sent the
review to our director of leadership
development because I thought there were
so many leadership lessons in here and
I said, we might want to get marine to
come to Google and tell us about this. Uh,
Maureen, you were running a
$5 billion global company,
one of the most iconic brands in the
genre of fashion and high end luxury.
And suddenly it stopped. Uh,
December, 2015 was it? It was,
it was January, 2016. Right.
So you've had this meteoric career.
You're one of the monkeys, Myers Ceos,
a female CEOs in your
industry, but also, you know,
an American CEO of this iconic
crunch brand. And then it stops,
I think, talk a little bit about what
it felt like and the disorientation.
Describe in the book. I would love to.
So there's a, there's a story in the
book and it's the first story and I'll
give you a sort of brief synopsis and let
you read the rest.
But you know,
from one day to the next I found
myself no longer with a, with a title,
with a label of global,
of Chanel.
And as part of what I was going through
I think, and I think, to be honest,
it was a moment for me
of both freedom in a way.
Cause I had been working in a company
for over 30 years in companies.
I had three major companies, L'Oreal gap
and all three divisions. And then Chanel.
And so while at one point it was kind of
liberating. It was, I was also grieving.
I mean it was really hard because I
found myself without knowing who I was
anymore. And the story goes that
I decided for whatever reason,
y'all probably think I'm crazy,
but I decided I need to purge my closets.
I have been wearing the
same uniform for 13 years.
I know it's a really wonderful treat to
be able to wear this kind of uniform.
For me it was jeans cause I, you know,
you can't give up your roots. So I had,
I had my, my denim jeans. Any variety
of denim jeans. What's your favorite?
Well, at the time, at the
time I was wearing j Brown,
but I've now transitioned to rag and bone.
I really liked there.
I'm giving them a plug. I hope they're
happy now. So all you Google earth,
I just think they're really comfortable,
well made and beautiful fabrics.
But I would wear any variety of j brand
jeans back then. My American apparel,
now they're going out of
business unfortunately,
tank tops and a Chanel jacket every
day, 13 years. That's what I wore.
So I had this moment,
I need to purge my closet.
I did that and I realized that all I
had left or tank tops a few woven shirts
from a company called Hartford and
these genes. So I thought, oh my God,
what am I gonna do? So I call it
Jeffrey is a store in New York.
I called Jeffery and I said,
are texted him. S O s I need,
I need clothes. I'm sorry, what
did you do with the old ones?
I know everybody has their about,
I don't know if you've just myths.
They're about 10 closets
full of my basement. But, um,
I still haven't done anything with them,
but I really, it was, you know, I know,
I know everybody. I know.
I haven't figured it out.
I haven't had time to figure it out.
But,
so I went into Jefferson
and I'm a merchant at heart
and meaning I love clothes
and I feel them. And I love to think
about what looks good in stores.
So I walked in probably the most
intimidated I had ever been because I felt
almost nude. You know, I
felt naked at this point.
I had on some of my converse sneakers
and jeans and I'm touching the mannequins
and they're looking down
at me and I'm thinking, you
know, I don't belong anymore.
I don't know where I belong.
And fortunately thanks to the team there,
they littered the, the dressing room
at all different options. And you know,
my first instinct was to go over to
my old identity, cause by the way,
this is a story about clothes,
but it's really a story about identity.
And I started looking at all the jackets.
That's all I could see was fitted jackets,
Chanel type jackets. And they said, no,
why don't we show you some other things,
wide leg pants and you know,
this kind of jacket and an underpinnings
and all these things that I hadn't ever
thought about wearing.
And I started looking at myself in the
mirror and I thought, oh my God, I'm,
there's a person in
there beyond the label,
really beyond the label
of global CEO of Chanel.
And it was the beginning of the process
that I went through a rediscovering who
I was after this 13 year stint as the CEO,
13 years spent as Theo Chanel
hurting your closet is a metaphor for
purging your life. That's exactly right.
Yeah. Your marriage of 26
years, is it the perch that to
automatic way it was, you
know, it wasn't dramatic. It's,
it's interesting to be in
the situation where I'm,
and I think in honesty of wonderful,
wonderful relationship,
which is still there is a friendship.
And to recognize that and to
be able to say, can we be,
can we evolve this relationship from
what it is and go beyond our own labels,
basically cool to into a friendship.
And so Antoine, I call him,
I was banned. And so, um,
because we're best friends
and he lives in Africa.
His passion and his work is in,
is really in,
in setting up NGO's in Africa.
So he's living in Burgundy. Um,
he does a lot of work also in Uganda.
Um,
but I also realize that what
was interesting about our,
our relationship is so much of what he
had to do in so many ways was follow me.
And this allowed him to follow him. So it
was a real opening. And now I say this,
it sounds really easy, but I cried
for three months and I kid you not,
this was not an easy thing,
but it was a, you know, you're
right. It was a, it was a,
it was a kind of identity. It
wasn't, I even hate to say purging,
maybe a strong word,
but do you think had your
separation from Chanel not happen,
do you think you would have been
provoked to, to, to your label?
You know, it's interesting.
Um, my marriage,
we were separated long before
I left to Chanel. And um,
it was interesting for me actually to
go through that. I'm not this, I'm not,
I don't want to talk too much
cause it's going to be the,
I think it will be the subject of my
next book. I know I would love to,
I'd love to talk more.
I, we can talk. I, I,
cause I haven't formulated all my
ideals. Um, but you know, it was, and I,
I don't,
you know how sometimes when you're in it,
and I think I'm the way I'm
still in that you're not exactly,
you don't have a distance enough to say,
what did I glean from this? Or what,
what questions can I ask?
What observations can I make that might
help other people going through major
transformations? Um, I, you know, I,
I'm, I'm still in the transformation.
I think kind of, we always are,
right? But this one was a big one.
It's remarkable in so many strong
women are giving voice to what it is we
variance in life. Um, Sheryl
Sandberg, who was one of the founding,
um,
she was the founder of women at Google,
which was here I had just come out
with option B and her whole premise of
resilience and you learn,
you actually learn how through
a difficult transitions,
just how resilient you can be and
resilience himself is a learned skill.
Is that something that you've
been toying with or has it,
I haven't been able to read the book yet.
Yeah, you know, in fact,
very early on in my career,
I started learning this
notion of resilience and I,
there's a story in there.
When I was a young merchant at the gap,
now you have to understand,
I was at L'Oreal for three years.
I was pretty sure,
and I had no idea by the way,
that when I went to L'Oreal,
I was going to be a marketer.
I studied literature. So I'll
at least in the room, maybe some
out there. Hi, you always. But I,
um,
I studied film as a literary form.
So as looking at imagery and trying to
understand the emotion that's created
with image, and it was, I'd never thought
about that might be career marketing,
but how logical is that
really amazing at L'Oreal,
which is such a visual marketer.
Exactly. And so I fell in, in,
in really in the right place. But I'd
come from this three years and I had,
I gone on the road they sent,
L'Oreal has this great program where
they sent me actually to the north of
France, which is the industrial
part of France. I mean,
all my friends were going to, you know,
that could, that could desi on I'm,
and I'm in the north of France
with the coal mines. Um, and they,
and they actually asked you to sell
L'Oreal products out of a suitcase and
you're trapped.
You're basically traveling salesmen to
hypermarkets hypermarkets or three times
the size of your local
supermarket. I mean, at least,
and I would meet with these guys
and there's a story in there.
I met with one guy and he
buys, you know, he bought ps,
he bought sanitary concerns and he bought
hair gel. Now you can imagine, and hair.
And I was selling Moose that day and
you know, his hair's all slicked back.
And I'm thinking,
maybe I should change my marketing.
I've got the marketing speak and I'm
giving my sales pitch. And he's like,
finally, he said, no, no, no,
no. Look, let's, let's talk
about the UNCAP. How about,
you know,
how much will you give?
And we started going back and forth and
I realized that I actually had to step
in his shoes to understand. But all that
to say, I came out of L'Oreal. Sure.
I was a marketer actually.
Sure.
And I got to the gap and it turned out
they actually had advertising at that
point, not marketing. So they had said,
you know, you're going to be a merchant.
And I thought this is great.
I mean,
I like looking at beautiful
products and selecting them.
My interview with the CEO,
then Mickey Drexler had gone really well.
I picked out some bags. I'm like,
oh, I can accent. Well, not so fast.
I found myself pretty much in a sample
closet the first several months trying to
sort through all the very,
you know,
the disarray of different products that
hadn't been organized in several years.
And then I had to learn this thing
called the open to buy, which was a,
it's a tool that manager inventory.
And um,
I had a difficult boss and he
one day said to me, you know,
I had lost again, lost. I had not
knowing where some Paisley bags were.
And he got very angry at me and told me
he wasn't going to teach me the open to
buy, that I had to learn on my
own. I, you know, and this is,
I'm a young person and I'm
also the sole breadwinner,
so he had yelled at me to such a
degree that I found myself crying,
calling my mom, this is what you do
when, right. Call Mom. So My, you know,
my mom had at that point said to me,
and you're talking about resilience.
She said, well honey, I hate
to see you working so hard.
I was working 12 hour days.
I didn't understand this thing called
the open to buy. I never been a merchant.
I realized that it was way harder than
anybody had told me in the beginning or
that I at least had surmised. And so she
said, why don't you do something else?
I said, but I want to be close
to creativity. And by the way,
no Google at that time,
this was back in 1989 if I had
known I might've come here. No,
I love,
I love the gap so much,
but I was so wanting to be
close to that creativity.
I sit and I was watching the
old, the older, you know, the,
the levels above me and what they were
getting to do and are working with design
teams and picking these
beautiful close up for the store.
So I stuck in there and I said,
mom, I'm going to stick it out.
And I think it was a very early
lesson in resilience, the resilience,
which is basically for me about when
you care so deeply about something and
you're kind of willing to tough out some
of those moments that aren't as easy.
And I care deeply about being close
to creative. I love that story.
Uh,
but because there is something in your
twenties where you prompt this sense of
who you want to be professionally,
you really do have to learn your
stuff your way into it, Tony. And, uh,
the ability to be patient with yourself,
uh,
and learn the tools of the trade.
I think those are important lessons
because I often say too many Googlers who
are by and large,
a very high capability,
ambitious group. You're going to
be working for probably 30 years.
This is a marathon and enjoy this journey.
So you had quite a journey through,
okay. Marketing, merchandising,
and then what I would call
leadership. Yeah. Yeah. You
were, you were senior of
the gap when you left work.
No, no, no, no. I was, I was president
of Banana Republic. That's it.
All right,
so now Republican and then
to be selected or a Chanel,
maybe you have an unusual
profile. You're bilingual, right?
You had worked in Krantz earlier,
but that is a leadership
daunting leadership.
Remember we talked sometimes at
Google about imposter syndrome.
When you show up somewhere,
if all of a sudden you realize,
wow,
everyone else is really knowledgeable.
How did it feel walking into the story
of house of Chanel and taking up your,
well, first of all, it was incredibly,
incredibly exhilarating and intimidating
and I remember standing in Gabrielle
Chanel's apartment,
it's beautiful.
Crystal Chandelier and I
talked about this in booking,
gazing up and then going to these fashion
shows in the 17th century convent.
Cool. And, and the, and and you
know, the beautiful detailed,
intricate couture. I had never seen
anything like this. And then here's a,
here's a brand that has a hundred year,
almost a hundred here.
Your history and gap is that was created
in 1969 and so I didn't I that the
richness of that and how do you take
that forward into this very different
future was going to be, I knew one of my
biggest challenges, but as the story go,
who is, when I started in CEO, so
this is after three years of training,
by the way, three years of training. So
I've taught, you talked about patients,
I think I learned to cultivate patients,
but the first year they had sent me
to France to just listen and learn,
put a tape on my mouth.
I said,
basically we launch in France
and then around the world,
we want you to meet
everybody in anybody you can.
I went into every single department from
creative to the factories to, you know,
finance visited with all the teams
and all I could do is ask questions,
which you said you're not allowed
to make a decision for a full year.
So that was humbling, very humbling.
And after about nine months I was going,
I want to do something.
And you know,
you're seeing these things
that you think you can do,
but this house has such a beautiful
storied history that you really do have to
learn the ropes first.
But when I came finally to become,
when I probably became CEO in 2007 that
was equally a hurdle because I actually
found myself at the table at the head of
a table of 10 men and all of them were
in their beautiful suits and cc logo ties.
Now I knew them because I'd been there,
but all of a sudden I was at
the head and I was 43 years old.
I'm American then most of them are French.
Most of them were a decade, if not two,
my senior.
And they all had,
not three years but about 20
years of luxury experience.
So that was the beginning of actually
tapping into a different kind of
leadership that I, you know, I had always
thought about leadership is, you know,
the idea of take charge, demand, respect,
you know, be focused, be strategic,
have a vision and that
wasn't going to work.
I wasn't going to work because
they had such deep history,
such such deep knowledge that I had to
figure out how I was going to integrate
the things I was seeing.
And certainly the digital world
that was coming out that, you know,
really 2007 was the beginning
of the major digital revolution.
And I had to figure that out.
So I realized that it was going to be
through asking questions through actually
sitting on their side of the table,
not trying to push my agenda and actually
being vulnerable saying, you know,
guys, I don't know this help. It was
it collaborating with them, you know,
mixing ideas and actually opening
questions to everybody so that we could
actually co create a future. And that
was that, that knowledge of that moment.
This is getting long. I'm sorry, but
I'll be good. So that, that was a PR,
that's a personal story.
But it taught me something really deep
about leadership because what I realized
during that moment, now this is three
major things were happening in our world.
The digital revolution for
you guys is incredible.
Now imagine yourself a luxury company
where it's all about exclusivity.
It's not more is more. It's not about
pushing sales are getting more exposure.
It's actually about making your products
rare and beautiful and connecting to
that customer. Not In en
masse, but one on one.
So the digital revolution
actually scared us.
So we had that as a great unknown.
And how are we going to be relevant in
this revolution if we are about rarity
and exclusivity. So that was the
first thing. The second thing was, um,
the globalization. We had been, we
had been global, but we hit the,
when the Chai China began to gain so much.
Well,
we had clients all over the world flooding
our boutiques from China and that was
hard.
We didn't know the culture that well,
but also we didn't know how to still
serve our loyal clients when the boutiques
were brimming. So challenge two,
challenge three and I'm looking, yeah,
I did all of you and
probably some of you there,
this generation that everybody's so fondly
called millennials for a luxury brand.
You know, and it's, it's
a patriarchal company.
It is based on a lot of history and you
have people who are born with devices in
their hands and who have a very different
perspective about what makes up a
luxury company,
not to mention mention different values
about ethics and social behavior.
So as I'm sitting at this table,
and you know,
this happened over a
period of a few years,
I realized that what I learned when I
came into the unknown and uncertainty
about how I should behave as a leader
was something that the leaders in our
company would greatly benefit from.
And that we as a company,
in order to step into this,
you know,
new age would actually have to adopt
new leadership behaviors and shift a
culture.
Were you explicit about those leadership
behaviors with your direct team?
Yes. And I'll tell a funny
story about that. Um,
so I had a coach and I had begun to
realize that these were things that were
starting to help me.
So when I could sit at the other
side of the table with my team,
when I could actually engage
in questioning and curiosity,
not only did our relationship got better,
but more ideas are starting to spawn.
So I said, great, I got it down.
I know what qualities I am going to teach
these guys what to do. And this point,
by the way, it added some
women to the team. So we were,
now I had added six women actually.
So I,
it was a rainy day in July.
July is not a good month.
I couldn't control the rain.
But July is not a good month in France
because it's a month before people go on
vacation and people leave
for months about. So very
busy people are stressed out.
Um, and I corral my team
into a dusty ballroom and I,
the ballroom was 10 times
the size of this room.
And there were 20 of us so you
can imagine what that felt like.
And then I had them play those team
building games, which sometimes are good,
but when you're in a group of Europeans
and when you know you're actually
forcing them to be out in the rain
because we did them out of the rain.
I don't know what I was thinking.
That doesn't go over so out.
And then I got up in my band,
Stan and I started to say, listen,
we need new leadership qualities.
We need to change our culture.
We need to be more empathetic.
We can to be more flexible.
We mainly have more collaborative. You
can imagine. Okay, so Ooh is right.
Biggest face plant of my entire career.
How they revolt immediately?
Well,
so pretty much pretty much.
I had also brought in some consultants
from California and that just wasn't the
right mix. They felt like,
I mean, you know, they can
smell it doesn't rain here. So
to say they felt like I wasn't taking
into account their perspective,
their point of view.
There are great history and all the
things that had made them great up until
this point. So I had one of
those moments where, you know,
your biggest errors are usually
your greatest learnings. And um,
August came, took some time off. I had,
I had organized an offsite with a great,
wonderful poet and speaker named David
White and that we had to cancel at the
last minute. I cancelled it. I canceled
it because I thought, what am I doing?
I didn't actually listen to it
for heed, my own advice. Um,
I actually need to let go
of my preconceived ideas
and collaborate with them on
how they see the future.
So while my ideas around
leadership might be valid,
I'm not going about this
the right way at all.
So I sat down with each team member
for over two hours, one by one.
I just tell me how you see the culture.
Tell me what you hope to improve.
Tell me what you hope to retain. What
about you? Where are you struggling? Um,
what are you ambitions? What's
your purpose? What do you,
when you care about and how
can you contribute to what
we're going to cocreate.
So I gathered all that 20 hours of,
of um,
interviews into some themes and we met
again and this time they were completely
engaged and we co created something
we later called active and conscious
leadership journey. Oh,
so listening was cute.
And acknowledging their expertise,
respecting their history and their legacy.
So the active leadership, active and
conscious leadership journey journey.
Can you tell us a little bit about
that with pleasure? Um, so I,
one of the things I also realized is
in any company there's a very specific
culture.
And while I respect lots of consultants,
I knew that actually in this
culture for this company,
it was going to be more about
really creating something very,
very specific for them.
It's tailor made and that takes into
consideration not just the culture of the
company, but the business issues
that we have. Right? I mean it's, it,
that's what we're ultimately you will,
you want to create an environment
or good business can flourish and,
and employees are happy. So, um, I
just said, we're going to design this.
I had a coach,
we decided that we would,
we would design it together and it
started with having outside speakers just
like today.
Only the difference perhaps in this
situation was we would take an outside
speaker and ask them to work
with us on our questions.
And so that we would have a session of
speaking and then we'd go into some of
the things that were going on for us.
So the first speaker was a wonderful
poet by the name of David White.
And everybody thought it was
crazy at first, but I'll,
if you want to hear that story,
we can come back to that. We had,
so Elworthy who was a peacebuilder and
had worked with Desmond Tutu and taught
us a lot about nonviolent communication
and deep listening, we went.
So the idea is you were going from
inside out. So who am I as a leader?
What do I care about? What
triggers me? What gets me excited?
Then who am I in with relation
to my colleagues, my team,
alumni with relationship to the
business, into the world. And so the,
it went from inside out,
started with David White,
went to Scilla and then we
started actually with some
business leaders like Clay
Christiansen,
we use Dan pink.
And so the idea was really
try to understand how do
you connect who you are as a
human being, as an individual to your
greater business purposes. And after,
so this took a, and there
was that component. We,
each executive had a
coach and this is in the,
in the phase where we were just
in 20 at 20 people. Um, and they,
I asked them to work on, so anything
they wanted, just one thing,
she's one thing and I mentored
them through that coaching.
So it was a very rich program
and it lasted for, I don't want,
I don't actually don't
like to call it a program.
I like to call it the journey and
the, yeah, because it's, it's,
it's actually leadership
doesn't start and stop.
It's something that we do all the time
and we're active and we're conscious and
it hopefully so Atlanta and ended up a
year long for this group and they were so
enthusiastic because by the end of
this time they were working in new ways
together.
New ideas were coming about.
Our business was on fire, on fire, and the
brand reputation and never been better.
So they wanted to roll it out.
They ended up,
and this is what was so amazing to me,
I get chills thinking about it.
They said we'll roll it out to the next
200 and so they took it to 200 people.
Now we couldn't afford coaches
for everybody, but there's a,
there are a lot of ways of getting good
feedback other than getting a coach that
200 Ben said, we love this. Can we roll
it out to 400 and by the time I left,
we were 600 strong.
It's a really powerful program.
And it did start to shift our
culture. I mean that was, you know,
meaning at the time with Google was
one of the beginning things, you know,
how do we get digital, how do we create
relationships with external vendors,
partners really how do we begin to create
those so that we can be relevant in
our, in, in our field.
You recall having visited
the Googleplex here,
not when you're with your team and
when you went back to Paris and,
or New York is when I first met you.
You were,
I think working between
parents always. Yeah. Um,
was there anything that shifted in your
approach that was conscious that was
sparked by something you experienced?
Yeah. You know, it was
amazing. We, so I had, I did a,
I chose actually I want to say 12
executives. I can't remember how many,
there were none of them executives
across levels to come here to Google.
We might to, um, Facebook. We might,
I mean we were really trying to get a
good sense. Pinterest at the time. Yeah,
it was, it was really, really
small. It was like in one room,
but it was really interesting.
We were trying to figure out how do we,
and we sat in a room and
shortly after Google,
we'd love the environment and Google.
I mean,
one of the things that
we've picked up on was this,
this notion of creativity
in any domain at Google.
And I don't know if that's
something that you experienced,
but it's what's what we
experienced meeting with Googlers.
It was like this freedom and ability
to express and to be in a creative mind
regardless of what kinds
of jobs you are doing.
And I Montessori I was inspired
by that. Totally. I mean,
and just the ideation,
you know, we drove in the,
in the driverless car and the kind of
ideation and forward thinking that I think
Google has was something
I wanted to learn from.
Because even though luxury companies,
one of the components of being a luxury
company at the highest end, his history,
you can't ignore the future.
And if you get stuck on history,
then you've got a problem getting into
the future and you ha that's a balance
that you have to.
Um, actually France has
that problem. I loved reds.
I went to university for a year in Paris
would there upward and increasingly I
feel back there on business quite a bit,
but it does feel a little stuck.
I felt that before a little
messy and like beautiful places.
French are extraordinary because
they have exquisite taste.
They understand beauty better
than I think any culture.
I mean Italians also doing,
they have a different,
I think a different way of expressing it,
but the French in terms of food and wine
and five minutes. Yup. And you don't,
I and I feel like that is
a gift for any culture.
It's a gift to the world.
And if you know,
just not unlike luxury brand like Chanel,
if there was a way that we could all
benefit from that gift and make it
contemporary enough so that we can
connect to it, I think it'd be beautiful.
I mean,
one of the things that I'm seeing with
luxury companies today and something I've
been watching quite carefully
is this notion of purpose.
And our Google has a great purpose and
I can feel it and luxury companies,
some of them do and some of
them are still developing that.
And purpose to me isn't
just about adapting a cause.
It's when the cause and who you
are connected yeah. Is Intrinsic.
So I think about Tesla for example, now
that, and then you look at their luxury,
they've made a luxury car and they,
their sales have been better on their
top model then BMW, I think, and,
and Mercedes.
Um,
but what's so interesting to me about
Tesla is you have all the fittings have a
luxury car because it's a
beautifully appointed. Um, Eh,
it's a technological innovation and yet
it's for you feel good about driving it
because you're not putting
more carbon or Max at, into,
into the environment.
And it just,
there's something about that to me that
feels really relevant in luxury brands
today, is how do you figure out how
to connect to today's consumers?
Connect to what we care about in the world
will still having a luxury offer in a
world of seven and a half billion people,
most of whom they could ever afford
something, which now would be a lipstick.
And that would be an indulgence.
Um, that's a, that's a call.
That's a tall order for
a brand like Chanel and,
and to make it accessible yet
still retain its luxury. Indeed.
But if you look at, you know, what a great
brand to do that, and you have a story,
a true story,
a legendary story about a
woman who was an orphan.
She was a complete orphan.
It's a rag to riches story.
She became a cortisone.
And then she finally started her own
tour business and became all the rage and
the top couturier in all of Paris.
And besides,
she changed the way women could dress.
She liberated us from corsets
and long dresses. So that is,
is for me that's a contemporary
story that, you know,
the iconic clastic perspective, the
subversion, she took men's wear fabrics.
No one had heard of doing this
into women's design. So you know,
when you have as richest revolutionary,
that's fair and you think about it
for women today. And I, you know,
I think about it for an and, and I
think there are other companies, I,
they're companies that are
doing amazing things, but it's,
I think it's slower for luxury
companies because sometimes, um,
the concerns have been
much more around that,
just that impeccably beautiful product
and service rather than thinking about,
so consumers have today, they're not
just in this transactional mode anymore.
They don't just want the label,
they want to go beyond the label.
Something about authenticity
that's really popping in, uh,
in,
in New York culture.
But I think you see it popping
up in retail around the world.
Love you to free associate. You worries
the Tesla. Obviously Chanel great brand.
We talked a little bit about rag and bone,
but the brands that really stand out for
you, that resonate with me right now.
I love Rei.
I just think it is amazing
opt out on black Friday.
It's not just a marketing move and you
know that because they care about being
outside and, and you know what I
think, and I think about luxury this,
this may sound crazy, but what does
luxury today, it's time, right?
Both said that at the same time
it's getting outdoors, you know,
because that's rare in rare it's
connecting with friends and with oneself.
So I love Rei for the way that it taps
into the outdoors and what it means.
I actually think Nike's doing a really
good job, big company, but you know,
equality has no boundaries.
That is, to me, I,
that made me want to run out and buy Nike.
So I,
they're connecting to something I care
about and they're still making great
innovative products do you can't forget,
for me, the product is still the,
you know, you've got to have a great
product. It's, it starts with the product,
but you also have to today
off of more than that.
And I think those are the
two examples. Just, you know,
that I've been kind of following
a bit. I was looking at, um,
does anyone reformation? Does anybody
because they want to know that, that yeah,
it's a, it's an online
clothing brand that's really
going after ethical sourcing,
ethical products and things that don't,
that don't rob our environment
of natural resources.
And I think it's an interesting
concept. I don't know what, you know,
where it will go,
but I,
I'm hopeful that we can get more of that
kind of attitude and environment into
fashion.
Did you,
for how long did you know
you had a book inside of you?
Because that's a brave thing to do.
It's time consuming,
very extremely personal and
intimate and you share it,
you're vulnerable. You don't know what
the reaction of the press will be.
Els, fair haired CEO, everyone knew.
And now you're an author with a
completely new orientation towards your
professional life. Uh, which
is still a journey. Absolutely.
Where are you itching to do this
for a while? I never considered not,
it's funny cause I, any of my
jobs I've never considered before.
I kinda got at the doorstep of them
that that's what I wanted or could do.
So with writing, I was a literature major,
sounds kind of logical. And I, I've read,
I love reading, I love
stories, especially fiction.
And so what happened is when,
when we did the active and conscious
leadership journey, I wanted to share it.
I really wanted to share it.
And I started with an article,
could not get the article
down to a reasonable size.
And I met an independent editor who
said, listen, you know, had asked me,
was a great asker and was pulling
ideas out of me and I thought,
and she said, why don't you write a
book? And at first I was like, oh,
I can't write a book.
And I realized that actually I had a
lot of things that I had learned and
stories that I wanted to
share to provoke questions.
I ask questions in the book,
um,
observations so that I could help other
people create their own paths to success.
And when you read the book,
you'll see it's not a set of
rules or dictates or how to, um,
I don't give a lot of instructions because
I feel like everybody has his or her
own journey. But this is really
about reading, opening somebody,
somebody else's journey up,
asking yourself some questions,
looking in the mirror
and, and, and, you know,
using some of those
observations for your own,
for your lives and for your own careers.
You're clearly a courageous person.
You were a teenager, decided to
study abroad in France one summer,
fell in love with goat cheese,
left me more about that.
And that somewhat set you on a
trajectory that has you here today.
I mean, did you consciously know
that you're a bit of an adventure?
You know, I, I don't, I don't
think I thought of it as adventure.
I fell in love with friends.
I think I'm very curious.
I'm exceedingly curious,
but I fell in love with the notion of
France because my father spoke really
fluent French. He learned without
a textbook. And believe it or not,
I think that was so
interesting and so effective.
He split it with beautiful accent.
So I was, I looked up to my dad,
I wanted to speak French. I came, I had
a great French teacher and I decided,
I got it in my head one year.
I said to my parents,
[inaudible] shoes,
I must live in France.
I must go be with a family cause I have
to have this language, this language.
I want to learn it too, except that nobody
can, nobody can tell I'm an American.
And the only way you can do that I think
is really other than my dad's schooling,
which they weren't doing in my school,
is go immerse yourself in the culture.
And so I landed in the south of France,
which was incredibly lucky. And I,
I stayed for a month with a family
and my father was a gal, has east.
So he was a mechanic and I got
to work at the gas station.
And every morning the table was set with
fresh wild flowers and the light would
glow on the limestone and
I would smell the lavender.
And my senses just broke open.
It was almost like I didn't know that
I cared so much about these things,
but the beauty, the sheer beauty
and their appreciation of it way,
they take it in the lecture hall,
which you know,
which is the hour that you had the
drink at night. Everybody sits in the,
you know,
they pour the pest east and calm and
it's a moment to be together and it's a
moment to take in the surroundings.
And I found that
absolutely just refreshing.
Fascinating at the time
in France. And I had, um,
also later gone back as a college junior,
I found a roommate and she,
and you'll read about this and book
and she was very liberated about her
sexuality and about her body. And I
thought, that's cool. Cause I grew up,
I grew up in the Midwest
and you know, it was, I,
women really weren't supposed to
be sexual beings. Well I didn't,
I did not feel that way. I felt like,
you know, I'm, I was supposed to be very,
very careful with who I was and you know,
kind of buttoned up.
And so this liberation
really appealed to me.
I love that story. I'm going to invite
now. We have questions on the dory.
I can keep talking and I have
plenty I could ask Maureen,
but there are a lot of
people in the room there.
Mike's and there are dory
questions. So I don't want to, um,
completely dominate the Q and
a, uh, anyone in the room.
So motivated.
We're going to have to get you a Mike.
You can take mine for a second.
Okay.
Hi Maureen. Hi. So you mentioned,
um, we'll luxury means tool, uh,
everybody in today's society a
little bit tired and being outdoors.
So I'm also from Saint Louis
and I did a little Wikipedia
research earlier. So fraud.
You grew up in San Louis?
Uh, Clayton. Oh cool. Yup. Great for,
I know you went to John's morose.
I did go to town.
No secrets,
no CRM. We, it's like we know we
can speak each other's language. Um,
so I'm curious from John's were rose
in St Louis to leading one of the most
coveted fashion houses in the world.
How has your personal interpretation
of luxury evolved over time?
That's really interesting. You
know, I think I always loved luxury,
but I wouldn't have called
it luxury. I was, I just,
once I had that experience in France,
I realized that I love beautiful things
and just the, the make the way they feel,
things that smell good. Um, great, great
food things on the pallet things. It's,
I love music.
And so I think the initial thing that
drew me was beauty and not this notion of
luxury by the way. I find beauty in things
that aren't expensive. A lot of beauty.
And in fact,
one of my early experiences at L'oreal
was I was driving in coal mining country
and it was a foggy industrial area.
Um,
and I rolled down my window and I noticed
this purple mountain of coal debris
and it was glistening and sort of the
early morning hazy song. I thought,
that's so beautiful.
There's a beauty in that,
even though in a way it represents
something that's about hardship and about,
you know, difficult living
conditions. But that was the beauty.
The beauty wasn't the perfect aesthetic.
The beauty was actually the story at toll.
So that was my initial,
I don't know that I've changed
that much on that, by the way,
just cause to me luxury and
I think recently now I'm
realizing that luxury is so
much more than objects.
It really is this notion
of being able to have time,
being able to have space outdoors and
with the people who you love. To me,
that's what I think where I've evolved to,
but in the beginning,
and I think it's still in me,
that notion of beauty is imperfection,
not perfection. Yep, exactly. And it's,
and it's in the story.
It's in the story that there is beauty
and it doesn't have to be, you know,
this kind of aesthetic plastic thing.
Thanks for asking.
I am also from Saint Louis. Not just
kidding. Wow. I was going to be like,
you go St Louis.
I'm from Paris and by the way,
I love friends as described by American.
It sounds amazing.
So I want you to ask to you,
I've been CEO of Chanel from a long time.
What keeps you motivated and
how did you reinvent yourself?
Or this is yours to keep
being a great visionary CEO?
Oh, that's a great question.
Thank you.
I think interestingly enough,
it was pretty easy from about 2007 odd
because of what was happening in the
world and the,
and our business was exploding.
So I was being motivated just by trying
to actually keep this historical brand,
this incredible,
incredibly beautiful house moving into
the future without compromising or
sacrificing the things
that made it so special.
And it kept me motivated because
everyday there was a new, you know, we,
we'd wake up one morning and there was
yet another social media platform to
think, to consider, or we'd have
to, we'd have a new fashion.
What's great is you always
have new collection.
So there's a new collection
to figure out how to,
to communicate to your customers,
how to sell to your customers and
how to create desire all the time.
So for me that, that actually wasn't
difficult. What towards the end of,
I guess the last three years when I was
doing active and conscious leadership,
I was actually discovering
beauty and people.
And so what was really
keeping me motivated was,
was watching this team and
this big team and getting,
I mean hundreds of letters from people
who said that this work had changed their
lives. That was really,
really motivating to me.
It's like how do you in a company get
people to tap into what they love best,
where they can bring value and how they
connect that to the purpose of the brand.
And when you do that, and you guys
know because is such a great place,
when you do that, you get incredible
workout people and they're happy.
So that kept me really motivated.
Thank you.
Hi Matt. Hi Maureen. Thank you so
much for coming, uh, for having me.
Well,
I'm originally from India,
but I'm California for awhile.
Um,
so I had a question around the
inflection points in your career.
Could you speak a little bit about
like what brought you to your next
opportunity from L'Oreal to grab
to Janelle are so different.
Great question. So, um,
I moved to the L'oreal story is that
after three years I was there and I loved
it there. I was learning all
about marketing by the way.
I did not go to business school. So
there were, you know, there's all these,
I had to learn all the techniques,
techniques or technical terms,
what marketing really was, um,
ups and market segmentation.
And everybody around me had
gone to business school,
so I had a lot of catching up to
do. Um, but I realized that my one,
my one gift that I had is I could see
image and I can understand what emotion
was created. The thing
is, is after three years,
I didn't see a lot of women at the top
then, and it's changed so much. I mean,
I was now one of the best companies
for that, but back then it wasn't,
and in the meantime,
my husband had an offer to go
to Indonesia and I didn't want,
I didn't see myself there.
And so we decided to pick up
and come to San Francisco.
So this is the funny influction
point about getting into retail.
I would have never, if you had
asked me even lit, leaving L'Oreal,
can you see yourself in fashion or retail?
I would say absolutely not.
I'm a marketer. So I come to San
Francisco now, this is not so smart.
We didn't have jobs and we had about, I
don't know, maybe a month to have savings.
So that was it. And it was sort
of like you got to get a job.
So I started interviewing, this is, um,
I guess in 1989 I started interviewing
and I realized that I am at this point,
I have the label in my own head of
what I am. I have an expectation,
it's called marketers, you
know, fixed on my head.
So I go to the two packaged
goods companies, biggest in
the bay area at the time,
Clorox and del Monte. Okay.
Demonte doesn't call me back.
I mean they don't,
I don't even get my foot in the door.
I get one interview Clorox and like,
you don't have an Mba,
what are you doing here? But
also I realized, wait a minute,
I don't think I want to be on photo shoots
for toilet bowls like this. I don't,
this isn't, I mean I love, you
know, I respect them, but the,
I don't think this is right for me.
And so I'm walking down market street
and you ask about reflection point and I
see this poster of Miles Davis,
Miles Davis, jazz, great.
And his head is in his hands.
He's got this soulful look and he's
wearing a black tee shirt that says gap
Michael. I'm like, I
want a market that, well,
the story goes snail mail at this time.
I send my resume a week later,
whatever it was, I got a
call from the recruiter and
I said, so you know, he said,
when you want to do her, so
I want to market the gap.
You said you're a merchant.
I said, I'm a what? What would it mean?
What is a merchant do that
don't want to sell stuff?
Like I'm not a good salesperson.
I had learned that myself and the
north of France, I'm not going to get,
I don't think I should do that
anymore. So he said, no, no, no.
A merchant works with design teams will
make they help to create the products.
And the assortments and figure out how
much to buy and where to source them.
So that was the info. But the
inflection point, if I think about it,
I mean to two things.
One was being in a company where I wasn't
sure I could progress and wasn't sure
that I had the means to do what I really
thought I want to do it or at least
grow. Um, and then the second thing was
seeing that poster and saying, you know,
is that,
so that was one transition.
And then I guess the second inflection
point was getting that call from a
headhunter while I was at old navy.
I'm,
I'm still selling $5 to use out of the
back of a truck and they say a French
luxury companies interested.
Now at this point in my
life I was missing France.
We were living on the west coast.
Um, we've been here for 15 years.
And just the notion of working
in a French leisure, coming,
getting back to sort of my, my, it was a
dream. It was, it was absolutely dream.
And so,
and then I learned about Chanel story,
who she was as a person and I
thought this is, this is new for me,
this is going to be the next
challenge. So it, you know, again,
and I never imagined that I would be
doing that, I think ever in my life.
But it just sort of being open
and opportunistic in a sense.
And I'm seeing those things and
hearing those things. I mean,
of course I got that wonderful
call, but you know, it's funny,
I'll tell you the funniest story
about that. This is gap. Let's see,
what was it about 2001 when I got the
call was the center of the universe.
Back then Chenelle was small and
I thought it was a brand for,
you know,
older women.
Like I didn't know that Chanel could be
young and hip because it wasn't so young
and hip done.
So for me it was actually a huge,
it sounds crazy, but a huge risk.
I had moved my entire family,
my kids were 11 and eight, so
I moved him from, you know,
their cozy little noe valley
slash Tiburon existence to new,
to first to Paris for a
year and then to New York.
So it was actually religious risk.
And I didn't think, you know,
I didn't at the time I, you
know, I didn't, I wasn't sure,
but I ended up thinking, you know
what, there's something about this,
this feels right. Trust your
instincts. Long story, sorry.
But we're storytelling here today and
thank you for coming.
Um, and my questions,
but were there key mentors that you
had along your journey and what kind of
pivotal role did they play for you
and then to then inspire you to,
to mentor others? I uh, I have,
I have mentored so many people and it's
one of my favorite, favorite things. Um,
I have a lot of really amazing
mentors at both at gap, um,
and even at Chanel.
But one I think about mentors
cause it's kind of a hot topic.
We talk about it a lot and we talked,
especially amongst the women mentors.
And I think that's amazing.
But I would encourage all of you to
think broadly about the mentor because I
learned as much in so many ways from
my friend in France flu in the book.
Um, who is, who taught me about, you
know, being comfortable as a woman,
being comfortable in your own body.
I would say I would learn in so many ways
as much from her as I have some of my
greatest mentors,
like Jenny Ming who was running old navy
and Mickey Drexler who is the CEO of
gap. So at mentoring doesn't
have to be a hierarchical thing.
I think it's really about getting
somebody with whom you can share
conversations,
stories you can ask questions.
I made a lot of mentors will mentees I
guess is how we turn that have asked me
to, so what do I, what do I do about
that? And I never answer. Instead,
what would I do is I ask them more
questions about what they care about.
You know,
where they want to go with this.
And what ends up happening is they find
answers that are better than any answer
that I could give. And so I would, for me,
that means that mentors can breed a broad
range of people and it doesn't have to
be somebody who is really impressive or
higher up reading in your book you're
talking about just a fall on them is
getting comfortable in your own body.
You talk about spending a long time in
your career operating in a masculine
frame.
Uh,
when did you realize that wasn't working
for you or did it work for you for a
while and you just decided to go
beyond that label? Um, you know,
it's interesting.
I never thought of it.
I've never really thought of it
when I was at gap, first of all,
because I think we were such drivers
and business and while leadership and
management was incredibly important,
gap was progressive in this.
The one thing that cap had done for
me, I'd given, they'd give me a coach.
I'd already been working on my
own leadership capabilities and,
and learning even more how to listen.
I have a funny story in there about
the launch when making Drexler, um,
it taught me how to listen.
It was very tough story. Um,
and another one of those
embarrassing moments. But, um,
so I was aware of this in myself,
but I wasn't so aware that it would,
it would be the those feminine
qualities people by the way, I didn't,
I didn't label them feminine qualities.
Sociologists and researchers
are now saying these are
feminine qualities but can
be found in men and women in fact,
and happened to be intrinsic to women,
but they, they're both men and women
share these qualities. So once I started,
I didn't, I didn't notice that or
I didn't think about it that way.
I would say when I was at the
gap, um, once I got to Chanel,
as I realized that I had to shift from
the drive out of the strategy and vision
and focus and all the things that
had made me really successful,
that I had to actually use
those other things that I was,
I was also aware of and working on.
But those things would become more
important or not more important.
I get those things at least had to be
integrated and I think that's the one
thing I think about sort of this masculine
feminine thing that a lot of people
are talking about. I don't love the
labels. I really, I really don't. Um,
and I think you know, there, there's,
there's different people
have different qualities,
but what I see is that great leaders
actually combine so they know when to be
firm.
They know when to be strategic and focused
and determined and they know when to
listen and to be empathetic
so that they're the balance
of great leaders is what
I'm really intrigued by me. If you watch
great meters, you can, you can really,
really see that they are, they are
toggling quite a bit in different,
in all different ways I should say.
Multidimensionally
Maureen, thank you so much for
sharing your story. Thank you.
[inaudible] an incredible career.
And if you were to look back and talk
to your young self as you were just
starting out in your career,
what's the one piece of advice
you would give yourself?
Well, I'll tell you and
because people told me this,
I look back and I think about
this a lot too. Two things.
One is I was so serious and I was
so, you know, I was really a serious,
I took everything to heart all the
time and I had, and I still have it,
I'm working at,
it's work in progress,
but so my young self and my own self
share this, I have, I have, I have, uh,
I have a big self critic and I think I
would have actually just tried to quiet
the critic a little bit and I'm a times
that I was really beating myself up a
lot on the other thing, and we haven't
talked about this much here today,
but in life as those
things were talking about,
I have two kids and I was
traveling, I mean a lot, every,
every three weeks.
Just about,
since I was a gap and I raised both
the girls and on Sean was there as the
staff, the staff on Dad, which was
at that time, if the gap and the gap,
it wasn't so unusual. But at, you
know, I'll try the gap. It was,
and we took a lot of
flack and it was really,
there's a painful story
in there about this,
but I would've loved to have
some conversations with my
kids about what that was
like for them and what
that was like for me.
And I think I was so grateful to Antoine
that he was home and that he was taking
care of them, that I thought
everything's fine, but you know, in fact,
and you'll read in a book, there's a
story that everything wasn't that time.
And um,
the,
these are hard things to grapple with and
you're in a wonderful environment here
where you have flex, flexible working
schedules, but um, I do think it's, it's,
things aren't perfect in this thing
called perfect work life balance.
It's another label that's another label
that I feel I feel really uncovered.
It makes us feel, I think it,
it disappoints us automatically.
You set yourself up for disappointment
and fulfilling guilty as a mother or a
father, by the way. Yeah,
I call it managed disequilibrium
and sometimes work.
I like that sometimes family wins.
And as an individual,
you have to make sure you win every so
often because otherwise no one actually
wins. But, um,
knowing that it's never a PR
imperfect balance, it's liberating.
Yeah, exactly. Well, yeah,
you, you, you live with that.
The sadness let me cry.
I cried on planes to Hong Kong.
I remember just leaving those little kids
and I didn't want to leave, you know,
lonely hotel rooms at night and it,
but you also know where you show
up and where you show up to me.
And for what for me was,
you know, I had two girls.
It was the emotional ways of crying
and mommy shoulder and you know,
hugs at night and just when I could,
when I could support them emotionally
and then schoolwork because Antoine is
French. So he didn't know the American
school system part as well. Um,
and trying to really, really be present
in those moments when you are there.
Um, I think is so, so, so
important. But I, it's not the,
not the extent that you get exhausted
yourself because when you're not present.
Yeah.
Um,
so the first question is,
can you share some practical advice on
cultivating sponsors and champions in
your organization?
Practical advice and cultivating
sponsors and champions in the, yeah,
I think that that's a great point
are great question. For me. Again,
it was about, and I think about my own
personal experience because by the way,
I wasn't,
I didn't necessarily have a Chanel that
many sponsors other than the owners at
the time because everybody, nobody knew
me. And while they wanted to like me,
my experience didn't fit the exact
profile of what they, you know,
what they thought she should
probably meet the company.
So it really was about listening and
about being on their side of the table.
And to get the Digi actually get
champions means that it's, for me, it's a,
it's a two way street. It's not
about convincing someone. Um,
it's not about telling someone what to do.
It's actually about living in their world
and with, with them and what they do.
And then you coach champion something.
Okay.
Did Mr Lagerfeld participate in the
active and conscious leader? You know,
isn't true. No. Isn't a no. Um, no, I,
I have been an oh, well I'll,
I'll answer that and I'll get you,
I've been such a huge
admirer of creativity.
I think when you think of creativity,
the word you think of Karl Lagerfeld,
you know, in the fashion industry. Anyway,
so what I, and I've worked with amazing,
amazing creative people at gap and
Banana Republic, old navy and at L'Oreal.
In fact, my early, early
experiences were at L'Oreal.
What I noticed is working with someone,
creative means giving them the space,
the resources to do what they do best.
And that, you know, to me that
was what was really important. Hi.
Um, it seems on your crave held a lot of
different titles and part of what your
success was was not holding herself,
redefining,
defining yourself to a certain
label. Um, but I was also wondering,
I think for a lot of people
in their career journey,
they have to sort of eventually
find somewhere where they
specialize in or where
like the,
like that's an area that they own.
So I'm wondering like how that journey
was for you and kind of figuring out like
what you specialize in or what skill
sets you bring to the table and then how
that evolved over time. That,
that's a great question. I
appreciate it. Um, you know,
I actually think there, I
mean, I always say the three,
the three groups of questions you asked,
you know,
what do I love so much that I
can't live without, you know,
beyond the label and beyond the roles
and beyond the definitions, what is,
what makes my heart sing? We're, can
I bring value? You know, what is,
what is my greatest gift where,
you know, where can I cut and,
and how do I connect those two things
where I bring value on what I love and
then what, you know, sort of answer your
question, what context am I, am I in?
You know what, sometimes you have to take
jobs that you don't like for a while,
but I found that always staying really
close to what I cared about was something.
And I learned it early on. And L'Oreal,
there's a story in the book about this.
But, um, so here I had not
been to business school and
I was in marketing and I,
and everybody else had.
So I didn't have that advantage and
I had to figure out what it was that,
you know, what was my path to your
point, what was it that I really,
really wanted to do and what, what
was my mark? And it ended up, I, we,
I got invited into some advertising
meetings and the art director and an
advertising agency,
I just,
I felt a connection with what he was
trying to do and we had this big oval
tables and I would find myself
like kind of scooching over to the,
to the advertising agents side,
you know, you're supposed to,
if it's client agent back in those days.
And I,
I found myself wanting so badly to see
through his eyes and it turns out and we
became friends.
He's the one who taught me about jazz
and we became friends and spent a lot of
time and he spent a lot of time
showing me how he sees buting,
which was how I thought about beauty as
kind of an imperfection because he was
showing me models and they might've been
plastically perfectly say, but she's,
she's not giving something
in the camp to the camera.
Like he talked about it in such a cool
terms. So I think, um, you know, from,
from my perspective,
it was really kind of tapping into that
what it is I care so much about and how
can I bring value and in that environment,
for me that was one case I can bring
value because it was different from what
most of what most everybody knew. Most
everybody was doing more classic market.
That's everybody. There
were great. You know,
you said it's a greatest that a company,
but for me that was
really what we'll counter
if we have time for perhaps one more
question. Anyone in the audience? Sorry,
the Dory. Oh, a gentlemen. I'd love it.
Thank you again, very much. Reading. Um,
so you've worked both in Europe
and here and t you were of course,
a female in a fashion world
with stereotypes about
women and dominated by May,
let you know, executives. Uh,
what is your comment about
the attitude that, uh,
you're showing France visuals but was
here and how this has changed over the
year and what do you think are,
I know there are a lot of,
there is a lot of room for improvement,
but some suggestions about how to improve
the attitude to the women and getting
to that state of really, you know, uh,
equal, uh, no discrimination.
Right? But the idea,
thanks for that question. Um, first
I'll say, you know, it's interesting,
I worked around the world, so not
just in France, but all over Europe,
all over Asia. And each culture
is different and it's, you know,
it's almost impossible to even kind of
categorize them in terms of their views
of women. It's interesting. We were just
talking earlier because Eileen is on, uh,
the L'Oreal board, um, French
companies now actually have,
they passed a law several years ago
requiring boards have 40% women.
So while they may seem like you know,
more more bias in the workplace,
I wouldn't say necessarily
that that's the case,
although there are fewer
women in top leadership,
there are also very few women in
top leadership in this country.
And we're talking about 4%
CEOs that 4% of CEOS are women.
That is not a lot. What
I, my thoughts about this,
uh, are, are kind of clear
equity and pay is, you know,
obvious work life arrangements that
help both women and men as those are
obvious. I mean, we have to change these
things. We can't, you know, I, I'm,
I'm impressive. Google has
flex time. It's amazing.
But in my experience,
if we don't also start to integrate these
qualities of empathy and flexibility
and collaborative collaborative
skills and deep listening,
if we don't start to
integrate those many women,
many women won't ever feel as comfortable
or as confident or as natural actually
being leaders.
So I actually think that there's an
attitudinal shift that we need to make to
get more women competent in those roles.
You know,
past the ho I call it the hard stuff.
Meaning the,
the pay issues and the,
and the work life arrangements.
We need to expand our frame of leadership.
We need to look at leadership differently
and consider that there are other
qualities both required for the world
but also that are intrinsic to women and
make women actually really good leaders.
And the good news about
this is by the way,
and there's research done about the
oddness that women leaders where women are
leaders and where there are boards, those
entities perform better. So, so you know,
this,
this is a win win for everybody.
Well that's a perfect statement in the,
uh,
talk on Maureen, we've had a lot of
discussion at Google on these very issues,
especially lately.
There's been a lot in the,
in the news around gender
parity pay parodying the
tech industry and we're very,
very convicted about ensuring that you
paid for the job you do not for the
person, the bar, um,
talent and tenure and
performance in the role matters.
But gender has no place in that equation.
So thank you Maureen,
you are active and conscious
leadership journey with us. Thank you.
See it is you're on the journey and
there's a lot more interesting acts that
we're going to read about or hear about.
So best of luck to you.
Thank you for spending.
Thanks everyone.
Thanks.
Do [inaudible].